the Austin McBroom ripped you off yeah
he did and he attempted to rip off like
every single fighter on the card which
is like pretty she went in there
promised an amount for every single
person take time off of their actual
careers for three months and only focus
on one thing for most of us not to even
get paid which suck he ripped off the
artists that performed he ripped off the
investors he ripped off the fighters and
I'm surprised that he's actually still
getting opportunities that's what it's
blowing my [__] mind he went out and
didn't have another boxing event yeah he
did with kids and I mean it did
absolutely terrible well I'm not
surprised but who the [__] would work
with him after that and he promised you
five million right yeah that's a pretty
fat payday yeah did you get any of that
I mean I got a small amount compared to
the 5 million but I mean I still got
something which is nice and then um
we're still working on it legally to get
the full amount okay so that's why
that's why I'm still okay with like
social gloves doing their thing yeah
please make money yeah just make money
so I can get paid you know